you you have two boys do they help in
the kitchen now uh yes four and two Hugo
and Gus and T Test they they uh tell me
what to cook they try to help and I'm
their private chef and no matter what I
make they almost never eat so it's a
problem for me and that actually makes
me feel good cuz when I do cook I'm like
do you know how hard this was for me I
don't do this and I feel like I did a
good job and they do not eat it and I'm
like it makes me feel good that you're
an actual chef and yeah they just are
like hard past where's the mac and
cheese yeah they want mac and cheese
they want all shades of brown Foods
beige my son eats anything beige
anything mine I even it's gotten to the
point where I I definitely take orders
but I have to actually just at this
point with Miles I said the other day he
doesn't eat vegetables and I mean like
has not a carrot stick it's just like a
big my son will not yeah he's like abely
no one wants to admit to that but then
like I was like oh no it goes past that
like I can offer him a root beer float
like he doesn't want to try that he
doesn't want to I'm like please try this
Coca-Cola like and then I'm like why am
I being why am I trying it's just my son
is the same though he will I have to
sneak it in into a cup that is colorful
that you can't tell what the color is
and that's how I sneak it in it's like a
juice or a smoothie he will not do it
and he will smell it out and be like
this is a vegetable and he is like hard
against it yeah same I mean and it's
like I I could make him sit there you
know whatever but it's just doesn't work
he'll He he'll sit me out he will be
like oh this table all night long before
kids you're like if they don't eat what
I make then they're going to bed hungry
I'm like no what would you like sir oh
no I will say if my son were here
eatting I have sent him to bed
hungry I cuz usually I'm tired I'm like
I just did this if you didn't like it
that's your problem I'm like I'm like I
said I made exactly what you said and
then
[Music]
whatever
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home